So in the past, I've told stories about how
broken our health care system is through personal
experiences I've had with the health care
system.
Of course, many of you remember the appendectomy
incident, which I described in the YouTube
video titled My twenty seven thousand four
hundred ninety five dollar appendicitis.
That was a doozy.
Back in late twenty nineteen.
There was also what we now know of as the
podiatry debacle.
That was earlier.
Twenty nineteen.
You can hear about that in the YouTube video
titled My eight hundred and twenty nine
dollar ten
minute long doctor's visit.
I have a new one for you today.
This one comes to us from the world of Auto
Reino Larranaga Allergy, as many of us know
it ear, nose and throat medicine.
Now I'm not telling you this so that you as
a European viewer can write to me and say,
David, this would have cost me zero out of
pocket in my country or David, this would
have been twenty bucks in my country.
I know that, I know that please don't email
me about it, OK, it's a look into our health
care system.
I know how well yours is working.
I don't need you to tell me, David, that would
have been free out of pocket for me.
So I, as a self-employed person,
get my own
health insurance through what are called the
exchanges.
And for years I've had what is called a silver
level plan.
Now, the gist of how this works is bronze,
silver, gold, platinum.
The higher you go, the more you pay each month.
But in theory, the less you pay for services
as you use them in terms of co-pays and deductibles.
So like a bronze level level plan would be
cheaper monthly than my silver plan, but it
would typically have a higher deductible and
a higher copay that needs to be met, the higher
deductible that needs to be met before the
insurance will cover anything.
Silver plans cost more, but they cover more
gold and platinum.
You might end up paying a thousand dollars
a month for a single person, but you might
have really, really cheaper.
No co-pays.
OK, fine.
I've had a silver level plan for years and
my premiums have dramatically increased, as
have my co-pays.
So for the same plan over the years, in 2018
I was paying for 39 a month and my specialist
copay was forty dollars in twenty nineteen.
It went up to 450 for a month and my copay
went up to fifty dollars in twenty twenty.
I was up to four Seventy-eight a month and
my copay was up to seventy dollars.
And this year I am paying five hundred and
twenty dollars a month and my co-pays are
up to seventy five dollars.
So right
now.
I pay five, 20 a month, that's 60 to 40 for
the year, just for the coverage, that's if
I use nothing, I guess I get an annual physical
for that right now.
I am paying that if I don't avail myself of
any services.
But I'm aware that
for lab work like blood draws and MRI's, CAT
scans, I have a two thousand dollar deductible
to meet.
I have to pay the first two grand for that
type of labs and MRI and that type of thing
before my insurance will cover anything.
So I've been having some ear pain.
My dentist thought it was caused by clenching
my jaw at night.
Might be a TMJ type of thing, but it's been
going on
for a while.
So eventually my doctor said, go see an EMT
to rule out other things.
So I'm thinking great.
I pay five 20 a month for insurance.
I know my specialist copay is seventy five
dollars.
I make an appointment, I get a referral.
I confirm this doctor is in my network.
I'm good to go with my seventy five dollars.
I go last week.
Doctor looks says things look good.
Let's do what's called.
I just want to look in your throat.
Let's do a laryngoscope.
Meaning they put a camera into my throat through
the nose.
I don't recommend it, it's not fun but it
was medically what my doctor wanted to do.
Let's do an auditory workup to test your hearing
and make sure you don't have like a You Station
tube issue.
I say, sure.
Now this is all stuff that was done in the
office.
So when she suggests it, I said, yeah, let's
do it.
I'm here.
Yeah, let's let's do what you want to do.
So everything looks fine.
It's probably TMJ from clenching at night.
I've got a diagnosis.
Fantastic.
I pay my seventy five dollars and I go home.
I now
get a bill
saying that this was a thousand thirty three
dollars visit and I'm going to owe almost
another five hundred dollars.
And I say, wait, wait a second, how can this
be.
I paid my five twenty for my insurance.
The doctor is in network.
I had a referral, I paid my copay.
I don't have a deductible for specialist.
How do I owe another five hundred dollars.
Well, I look closely at the bill and it says,
That's right, David.
The office visit was billed at four hundred
and twenty dollars.
Typical for specialists.
You paid your seventy five.
My insurance good for them, negotiated a discount
so they add another ninety two dollars and
the office visit is paid.
But then here we go.
That camera in my throat for thirty seconds.
That's another four hundred dollars.
David the audio.
Mitry that's another
one hundred and forty dollars.
The ten banana tree which is five seconds
to check the pressure in my ears that's another
fifty dollars.
And lo and
behold that's billed like a blood test that's
billed like an MRI.
So even though I'm in a room with the doctor
and she looks in my ears with one
tool and
looks in my nose with another and then puts
in a camera, the camera
is
a completely different type of thing that
is like lab work or an MRI or blood work.
And I need to meet my two thousand dollar
a year deductible, which of course I haven't
met because it's March now.
Thankfully, my
insurance did me the favor of negotiating
better rates.
So even though the camera normally costs four
hundred, they've negotiated it down to two
eighty.
For me, the hearing tests, they've negotiated
down to one ten.
So bottom line, in addition to my seventy
five dollar copay.
And paying five for a month of health insurance,
I owe an additional four sixty six in essence,
if I didn't have any insurance, I could have
said, do you offer a cash discount?
I might have paid a little more for some of
these items.
I probably can't negotiate as good a rate
as my insurance company can, but I would have
avoided paying the 520 a month in premiums
all along.
So needless to say, I'm thinking about maybe
I switch to something called direct primary
care and then a high deductible plan and kind
of self insure for the higher deductible.
It's a mess.
If you're in Europe, don't email me.
I know this would have cost you nothing out
of pocket.
You don't need to make me feel any worse.
But that's another bit of insight into the
American health
care system.